5 26 into wednesday morning here are
some specifics on how ndot's ginormous
tropicana transformations going to play
out
we're also doing a lot to increase
pedestrian safety in the area and that
spokesman justin hopkins on any given
day whether it's an event at a legion
stadium or whether it's an event at
t-mobile arena or just tourism on the
strip there are tens of thousands of
people that walk across that area and so
sidewalks are going from five feet to
ten feet wide we're adding some new
pedestrian lighting and pedestrian only
paths the first phase of the project
from now until the beginning of next
year also includes the installation of
ten new of those big traffic signs that
go over the freeway
that are going to tell you when lanes
are open or closed or speed limits and
things of that nature
we'll for sure be keeping you up to date
with probably more reports than you want
to see and hear about the i-15 and drop
but i cannot recommend enough the n dot
website that's all about the project
keeps you up to date that link in the
online version of the story at our
website when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully put down that phone something
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com